foreign
foreign FTA
channel is
foreign
[Music]
DJ
Ango Kung
um
[Music]
Hungary cheers
foreign
[Music]
programming
Horizon Europe
an
is
[Music]
foreign
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
during the current War many European
countries sent their soldiers to fight
alongside South Korean soldiers
including my own country
as a Belgian and European I am strongly
attached to the trolls you know only
Moro de melon even resigned as Belgian
Minister of Defense to come and fight in
Korea a total of three thousand Belgian
soldiers served during the Korean War
and they played a role at the Battle of
izmil river which I crossed this morning
on my way to the demilitarized zone
Mr President it was a pleasure to meet
you for our 10th EU Republic of Korea
Summit this year is the 60th anniversary
of the bilateral relationships between
the replica of Korea and the EU
career is one of the eu's most valued
Partners in the region we share German
interest in common doors we are united
by the values of democracy human rights
rule of flow international law and today
we took another step to strengthen our
strategic partnership by focusing on
important Regional and Global challenges
and on our bilateral relations
today we Face threats to our Global and
Regional security and Rising Global
competition
this Summit takes place as Russia
continues its large-scale attacks on the
people of Ukraine
these threats and this war
show that deeper cooperation between
and the replica of Korea is not a luxury
it is a vital necessity
and I would like to send you the present
in Korea for condemning this illegal war
against Ukraine and for your support for
the people of Ukraine as they bravely
defend their Homeland
ladies and gentlemen oceans May divide
us but European and in the Pacific
security are closely connected so we
must stand United and firm to protect
the U.N Charter and the international
news-based order
in this region the DPR case nuclear
program and weightless missile tests are
a serious threat to International and
Regional security
the EU does not and will never accept
nuclear Armament by the back door in the
EU will continue to support your efforts
to build peace and stability on the
Korean peninsula
these challenges also highlight the
importance of strong reliances to face
today's new challenges boosting
cooperation with your closest neighbor
to enforce this stability in the region
and help to achieve our shared goals we
also stress the importance of preserving
stability and the status draw in the
Taiwan Strait
ladies and gentlemen we are working
together to build the dynamic and rules
based in the Pacific region to make
progress in areas like climate health
and security and defense and we are
working together to build new security
Partnerships just one example would be
the current Navy participating in the
youth operation Atlanta the Houston
Paris military operation of the Horn of
Africa and in the Western Indian Ocean
we are also forging closer ties in our
bilateral relationships and the pinned
by robust agreements like our
three-tailed agreement and today we have
Again country deliverables in green
health and digital topics we are joining
forces to modernize our economies by
making them Greener this is good for our
planet and due to our societies our new
green partnership will boost the
operation in areas like Renewables and
Green Technology importantly through
this partnership we will strengthen our
cooperation on the safe operation of
nuclear power among other issues we are
also teaming up to improve Global health
and this includes making sure the world
is ready for possible future Health
crisis not to be through a new wage or
pandemic agreement
digital
and will be more and more the life bloat
of our future societies and that's why
we launched our digital partnership last
year to cooperate more in critical
Technologies like semiconductors Quantum
Computing and artificial intelligence
and to Foster greater cooperation
between trusted and technologically
advanced partners
Korea is a global leader in
semiconductor production and now we are
committed to deepening our cooperation
on digital trade rules
the EU and your country have a powerful
trade relationship EU is first investor
in Korea and the third trading partner
for Korea it's proof that our Free Trade
Agreement is a success story for both
our citizens and businesses in trading
dudes it has grown by 70 percent since
2011 and we want to maximize its
untapped potential
finally Awards on Economic Security
we have just returned from the G7
meeting in Hiroshima where we discussed
the interdependency of Global Supply
chains within tune we also focus on
strengthening the residence of our
supply chain especially in strategic
Industries and for critical technology
and raw materials the president and
should regain for your warm welcome you
can count on the EU to promote peace and
security and to protect our shared
values and the international law I look
forward to seeing you in Europe soon
thank you
foreign
thank you for hosting us here in Korea
today the Republic of Korea is most
definitely one of our oldest and closest
partner
one we trust and we count on
this year marks indeed the important
milestone for us the 60th anniversary of
our bilateral relations
and it's quite amazing to think back to
1963.
the predecessor of the European Union
the so-called European economic
community
had just been established barely six
years earlier
Korea had emerged barely 10 years
earlier from war nevertheless
the partnership has developed and
blossomed
to become one of the deepest and richest
we have elevated to the rank of
strategic partnership in 2010.
and it is completed with one of the most
significant free trade agreements ever
signed by the European Union only one
year later
one that has delivered fantastically for
both sides
I mentioned this because the investment
we have both made in this relationship
have has never been more important and
valuable than today
in a world profoundly shaken by Russia's
war on aggression in Ukraine
Russia's blatant violation of the U.N
Charter and the international law
you condemned this war of aggression
from the start
you are coordinating tough sanctions
against the Russian economy of war with
us and other International partners
and you are channeling much needed
financial and humanitarian assistance to
Ukraine and its people
it is all to your credit and it shows
once again the strength of our bond
two democracies
sharing the same values
and a friendship that defies the
geographic distance
this is best shown by our people who
have a long-standing and Rich tradition
of exchanges especially through business
education and culture
trade figures testify to the dense
nature of our relations with an increase
by more than 110 percent thanks to our
Free Trade Agreement
a real success
that we continue to develop
today we came together to reflect on the
future of our partnership how to
capitalize even more on that special
bond we share
part of the answer lies in the
discussions we have had at the G7 Summit
democracies like ours must get better at
navigating geopolitical and economic
shocks together
we need to ensure our Economic Security
while remaining open
and promoting a healthy competition
among ourselves
so today we launched a number of joint
initiatives to that do just that first
we launched our green partnership
we will work on the convergence of our
regulations on carbon pricing on
deforestation
on Plastic Products
and explore joint projects in the fields
of Renewable Energy Efficiency and the
hydrogen economy
second we are launching negotiations for
Korea's accession to Horizon Europe
the eu's research program at the largest
in the world
we will get our Brilliant Minds to work
together on the Technologies of tomorrow
third we are signing an arrangement on
health emergency preparedness and
response this is also about sharing
crucial information about the situation
of Supply chains
and fourth we are pushing ahead with a
digital partnership we agreed last
Autumn by getting our teams to work on
AI for example high performance
Computing and in particular
semiconductors
I want to highlight that the EU chips
Act
can be a major Boon for Korean
investments in semiconductor
Manufacturing
and finally we should be able to start
negotiations on a digital trade rules
agreement still this year so that for
our partnership in strategic economic
sectors this is a wide range of topics
we concluded
we have also agreed to step up our
cooperation on security and defense
we will launch a strategic dialogue
extending to crisis management Maritime
security cyber security or
counter-terrorism just to name a few
and finally I want to talk about the
broader indo-pacific region
I want to reiterate in particular the
eu's full solidarity with you in the
face of the constant nuclear threat from
the dprk
the European Union will never accept
the DPR case possession of nuclear
weapons as a normal State of Affair
and just like we do not accept Russia's
military aggression against Ukraine we
condemn the dprk's constant nuclear
saber rattling We Stand firmly by the
Republic of Korea
finally we share much aligned Visions
for the future of this region overall so
we want to work with the Republic of
Korea on a positive agenda for the
indo-pacific we propose to do this and
our global gateway investment strategy
global gateway is already at work in the
region with an investment package for
the asean countries but we can do more
and there are a number of projects with
great potential for the region we
discussed transport corridors in Central
Asia the digitalization in Vietnam the
forestry in Mongolia many opportunities
for cooperation
I hope we can get them off the ground as
soon as possible and show to our people
that democracies can deliver and they
deliver best
and indeed
one only has to look at the phenomenal
success of the Republic of Korea to
prove this point
and this despite living under the
constant shadow of conflict
on a peninsula that suffers from
division into North and South
as a German citizen I know what it means
to live in a country long divided
between east and west
and I want to say to you you will
prevail
the future will ultimately bring
peaceful unification
because the longing for freedom
is ultimately always stronger than the
power of any dictator
so thank you again for your very warm
welcome
I look forward to seeing you at the G20
Summit in your daily this summer and at
our Summit in Brussels next year thank
you very much
[Music]